tens of millions of people from
Pennsylvania to Maine could face another
tough commute this morning as the fourth
nor'easter this month continues to
target the region icy roads caused more
than 1,100 car crashes in Maryland
Virginia and New Jersey at least two
people were killed more than 85,000
homes and businesses lost power Don
Dahler is in Beachwood New Jersey which
got 13 inches of snow Don happy spring
morning to you yes thank you very much
good to be here good morning all utility
crews were here a short time ago to
remove this tree that had fallen on
those wires and folks in this
neighborhood are waking up once again to
no electricity in fact of those 85
thousand customers in the Northeast who
are without power 87% of them are here
in New Jersey many of whom this is the
third time they've had to go through
that they're fed up and they want winter
to end heavy wet snow snarled traffic
across the Northeast as the latest
nor'easter slammed the region on the
first full day of spring the whole way
down here there was people spinning out
in Delaware ice and near whiteout
conditions caused hundreds of cars to
swerve off rows New Jersey saw more than
a hundred and sixty crashes and one
person died in New York when a van
tipped over on a highway poor conditions
grounded more than 4,400 flights at
airports leaving travelers stranded
we've had like six flights that we've
been trying to get on but everyone's
just gotten catsuit so far gusty winds
and dense snow left more than 85,000
customers powerless many of whom were
also without electricity in previous
storms there's a lot of older people
that live around here that really need
the power back on is they have a lot of
health problems I'm an asthmatic I have
a nebulizer machine so you know I have
an asthma attack with no power I'm what
am I going to do
New York's Governor Andrew Cuomo slammed
power companies for their delays in
restoring it the utilities are not a
charity we pay the utilities to provide
power when the sun is shining
and when the Sun is not shining the
storm is expected to move out of New
England this afternoon which puts the
focus on cleaning up and that means
restoring power clearing streets and
digging out as that guy fact Harris
doing Gail yep they got a lot of work to
do there Thank You Don